[Music]
let's go to lynn in sioux falls south
dakota what's up lin
uh not much how about yourself i'm doing
all right i'm doing all right
what's up lady how can i help
um okay so
um i'll just give a little backstory
first so my daughter was born in january
of this past year so she's seven months
um when she was born they noticed she
had a lot of fluids build up in her
um
kind of below her knee and her feet and
her labia a little bit as well
um so at first they thought maybe it's
just because she was cramped in the
birthing
position for so long but then it didn't
go away so we met with a geneticist and
they
decided to do two different genetic
tests on her anyway those both came back
negative so they decided to do a whole
exome sequencing on
my daughter myself and my husband and
then
um in june the results came in and that
we found out that she has milroy's
disease so
yeah
i know so it's a really rare um medical
condition they the genetic doctor we
have
been seeing told us that there's less
than 200 cases or excuse me 300 cases
like in medical literature it's just so
rare but um the biggest thing that comes
with that is just lymphedema right how
is that lymphedema is it is she draining
well or she's starting to have sores on
her feet how is how is it
um you know it's really well managed we
have a really good lymphedema therapist
good she was born in a really great
hospital um they caught it right away so
yeah she's been doing compression since
she was born we've um we actually have
been to the children's hospital of
philadelphia i mean we've been a lot of
good places so it's under very well
like it's being managed very well she
doesn't have she hasn't developed sores
on her feet or anything yet
um
not any current ones we've dealt with
that a little bit as of now it's been
all good
um she just had her first round of
cellulitis yeah but that's over with now
but that's kind of the biggest
risk factor with lymphedema is the
cellulitis but um what about mobility
um her mobility is really good really
good she's scooting around
yeah she's a stinker she's standing on
stuff i mean her mobility but yeah like
i said we've been working with a really
good lymphedema therapist and a physical
therapist and they've been watching that
the whole way so yeah she's right on
track of where she should be so cool all
right so how can i help by the way
everybody listen miller's disease is a
very very like she said very very rare
um just a dysfunction of the lymphatic
system and i don't know enough about it
to talk with any sort of eloquence about
it but
um
we have fluids drainage systems in our
bodies that things get expelled um via
urine throw our bowels like it's just
part of our system and
um this very rare disease
it you can get you can get over enlarged
feet legs sometimes it's one leg
sometimes it's both feet which is what
what does she have in both feet
yeah she has it in both feet both legs
and then um it's in her hands um and
arms slightly as well not to the point
yet where she has to wear compression
garments but yeah mainly in
both her legs and then her right leg is
actually a little bit worse than her
left so okay all right okay so
you are here
how can i help
so yeah my question is um
and if i'm trying to make it as much as
one question as possible but there's
kind of a couple little parts to it so
how do we teach her how important it is
as she gets older to
basically self-manage
her lymphedema and how do we
best
like
just really imprint it on her heart that
she's just so beautiful and then as my
as her mom i am the carrier of it i have
the disease as well i have no symptoms
which yeah 10 to 15 percent of people
that have it have no symptoms i have no
symptoms how do i deal with the guilt
um
of
yeah giving that to her
all let me i'm writing myself a note
here
um
[Music]
um
all of this starts with that
okay
you have to be very direct with yourself
are you married
yes yep okay um
you like who you're married to
he's a good guy yeah he's good he's he's
he's the positive i'm the worrier so
you have to
be very direct with yourself and with
him
and your adult community
about dealing with your guilt
okay okay
you know as much as i do that you didn't
cause this you didn't do this
and it was a
wild genetic
throwing a dart in the dark and it hit
the bullseye right
and so um
if your daughter sees you once
when you look at her
she'll internalize that
if your daughter sees you cry
or to somehow harbor guilt this is my
fault i can't believe i did this
um
children will make that disconnection
their fault and she'll try to solve it
in a million different ways
so the greatest gift out of the gate you
can give this little girl
is to make peace with yourself and make
peace with your body
and i also know that's a tall order okay
i'm not saying that's easy
um it's a similar conversation i have to
people who accidentally hit their kid
with a car or who hurt their child or
accidentally drop you know whatever the
thing happens to be
it's
making uh making peace
not making it go away not but making
peace this happened okay
and i have permission to be sad i'm
gonna do that with my counselor i'm
gonna do that with my husband i'm gonna
do it with my friends
and then i'm gonna be in this moment and
i'm gonna go about being the best
freaking mom who's ever lived which i'm
pretty sure you are
cool
yeah yeah okay
so step number one we're gonna deal with
our anxiousness and we're gonna deal
with our guilt
she is not going to do this because
that's not her job right
okay
so when it comes to teach a kid
self-advocacy how to stand up for
yourself how to do your things here's
where these get hard i've been working
with students with young people with
special needs for most of my
professional career
here's where this is challenging is
a
there's just a convenience it'd just be
so much faster i would put your
compression socks for you on for you so
we can get to this stupid restaurant
and what we do over time is we start to
deny our kids whether they have special
needs or exceptionalities or they're
just a regular old square in the middle
of the bell curve kit
we rob them of struggle
and when we rob kids of struggle we rob
them of growth and development and
resilience
so it's stealing from our kids
for a kid with milroy's disease it's
gonna be
harder
it just is
because if she has to put on
compression gloves and compression socks
every morning
gosh i think just getting my kid to find
socks
makes me want to set my hair on fire
sometimes
and then he'll like i
i was cleaning the garage are you any
random socks i found i mean so just
kidding with socks issues right
yeah yours is going to be challenging
and so
your plan now is
it's going to take us 50 minutes to get
ready to go to church or to get ready to
go to the out to eat when it would
normally would have taken us 10 minutes
15 minutes it's gonna take some time
but i'm not gonna rob my child of that
struggle
and they're gonna learn self-advocacy
another thing in a restaurant when they
bring our food
i don't say thank you for the whole
table
my kids say thank you for their
individual plates
i'm teaching them they have a role to
play in gratitude
that also so similarly if your child
needs something needs a wheelchair and
not when they're six by the way but when
they're 10 when they're 12 and they're
14 and you're at the airport you can
take her up to the counter holding her
hand
and say
tell this gentleman what you need
and she will say i need a
someone to push me from here to the gate
please
and they will bend down and look her in
the eye and say i got you
and she will learn the
beauty of mom's right here with me
and i just spoke my needs and this
awesome guy is going to make it happen
for me
see what i'm saying
yeah
that makes it so much easier for you
just to leave her with dad you run up
there and grab say hey my kid needs a
wheelchair in the bed gotcha so much
easier
that means we have to go to the airport
30 minutes early right you see what i'm
saying
yeah so yeah just we're gonna slowly
incorporate her into her own
life
right yeah
and that brings me to this
it's gonna sound counterintuitive okay
okay we're gonna be very direct
about what she has
might even show her that your leg is
different than her legs
that she's got exceptionalities
we're gonna call it out and we're not
gonna hide it
okay because kids feel
when we hide things
and then they feel even more of a big
giant red light bulb
in their life than they already do
we're gonna focus on what we're gonna do
not what we can't do and
man
um
we're gonna have hard seasons and low
times and good seasons and good times
and we're gonna make the best childhood
we can move them forward
yeah
so i just made it so easy right go go go
go go get them later i'm just like i'm
just taking it all um yeah and kind of
um
yeah i guess yeah another thing that i
just kind of worry about a little bit is
you know like
you know she'll never be able to get a
pedicure not worry about that but you
know should not be able to get a
pedicure should probably never be able
to wear
flip-flops and
you know when she wears shorts you know
i'm sure she's going to want to it's you
know it gets warm i just don't want her
to feel like the odd one out because
she's got these big
you know compression garments i just
never want her to feel like
she's not perfect you know the way she
is you know and i don't there's a couple
things here
don't ever
make her carry your baggage
yeah here's what i mean by that
my kid is growing up in a world where
there's an african-american president
my kids growing up in a world where
social issues are different where
there's not a table at his school that
just has people who listen to country
music at it and then another one that
listens to hip-hop and another one
listens to heavy metal like my high
school did
right
and so when i ask him where do you sit
he's like i don't know i just sit around
my head instantly goes to panic
if you're not at the right table dude
things go sideways for you
he has a different world that's not his
experience and so you have
understanding
of what it's like to
put on shorts
and not have people look at you she
won't have that that would be her whole
world will be her legs
yeah right
and so
yeah she's gonna know that and we're
gonna call it out
we're gonna call it out let's put on
some shorts and
um put on your special socks
and then we're gonna go about our day
and if people look and ask you can say
with her chin held up i've got milroy's
this means my body doesn't drain fluid
good you want to go play
yeah
you see what i'm saying and all the
other stuff doesn't come now make no
mistake middle school will be hell
high school will be tough right we know
that
yeah we know that
and
we can preventatively mourn that and
slip into this low-level dysthymia this
little level depression that just runs
our life
or we can just go reckless
with joy and good times and figuring
this thing out as we go and deal with
the heavy when it gets heavy
yeah that makes sense and i yeah i
totally agree yeah
she's going to feel beautiful if you
treat her beautifully
yeah
she is going to feel odd and scary if
you flinch when you hold her
yeah which yeah that's not how it is now
and you know like we love her and i just
yeah i don't yeah oh
middle school's gonna be awesome middle
school's gonna people are gonna ask her
but then she's gonna find her gang
right she's gonna fall in with her
people
and they're gonna do their thing
and then there's probably gonna be some
people who are hyper protective of her i
had a couple of friends like that but i
was hyper i still i'm hyper protective
of them
right and they're because they're my
gang
they're my they're on my team right and
she'll find that but so it's gonna be
both end
and by then you will have she she will
have five
10
12 years of advocacy
of pulling on her own socks even though
it takes forever of having hard
conversations of asking for support when
she needs it and
she's going to be able to just to
she's going to it'll hurt but she's
going to be able to move past that
nonsense see what i'm saying yeah
yes yes maybe move past it later on
being 12 just as hard being 12 right
yeah um
but we're not gonna hide our our
daughter she's beautiful
yeah we're not gonna hide her and we're
not going to pre-grieve things that
haven't come yet we're going to live our
life as as we are and there's also my
guess is some pretty extraordinary
medical advancements that are on the way
right
yeah yeah even from 20 years ago it
sounds like there's a lot of
you know
you know new things and good things
absolutely so let's keep our heads up
and when we get sad we're going to go to
adults with that sadness and we're not
going to we're not going to throw things
that our kids have to carry for us
and we're going to be honest and not
hide anything this is what this is
you're just shorter than the other kids
um
you
you suffer from milroy's you're not
gonna wear flip-flops
what would flip-flops be like they're
fine but you can't run in them
yeah and plus
uh
i i've never got a pedicure lynn and my
life's relatively fine
i would feel sorry for my getting a
pedicure for me would be like dumb and
dumber it would not be pleasant for
anybody doing my pedicure um i know
that's something dumb but no no but but
but an experience that mom wants to have
with it with her daughter
yeah okay i mean this brings me to the
last thing i'm gonna tell you then i'll
let you go okay
okay
when you find out you were pregnant
the picture machine started
and when you found out you were having a
little girl
you started thinking about what it's
going to be like when she brings some
idiot home from college you started
thinking about what thanksgiving was
going to be like
you thought about the wedding you
thought about all that stuff cause
you're normal and you love your kid
and then she was born
and then there was some challenges and
there was a testing and more testing and
more doctor visits and more testing then
they sat you down and said hey actually
there's this genetic thing
and all of those pictures have blown up
but what most of us do is we go about
our day comparing our reality with those
pictures that we made up before we even
had all the details
and it's that energy expenditure that
wears this out
and so the energy is must much better
spent moving forward yeah i had a
picture man of what this is gonna look
like it's not gonna happen it's gonna be
different
like mother duck i'm gonna take her to
get pedicures every saturday honey you
gotta make way more money because we're
doing this to get it's not gonna happen
so what is gonna happen that becomes oh
man every sunday
we're going to the beach we're going to
the water we're going swimming we're
going to whatever the thing is
the mother daughter time will still be
right so you see what i'm saying it's
just adjusting that picture
yes and it's so hard
i would recommend
writing a letter
to that old picture here's what i
thought was going to happen
you may even start a journal that she's
going to be able to read someday
but things get heavy
and she'll know just how much mom loved
her
okay
but i can do that but writing something
down that says
i had this picture i thought we were
going to get a bunch of uh pedicures
together i thought we were i just had
pictures of us running in the beach and
our flip-flops and having cute toes and
i just said the word cute toes and so my
brain malfunctioned a bit but i had this
thing and it's not gonna happen so now
what now what
most of us spend so much energy
myself included lin going back and
trying to edit sentences that have
already been written they've got
exclamation points or periods at the end
of them they're over and i keep going
back i wish i hadn't said that i wish i
hadn't done that i wish this could be
different i wish my kids could i wish me
and my wife could
they're over
it's over
the only thing i can affect
is what's gonna happen moving forward
i thought this was gonna be that way
it's not
so now it's gonna be like this
and the one thing in the world i can
choose that i get to own
is that
gap between what is reality and what
could be
i get to choose what going forward looks
like
and you can too